bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv dans
ce cadre exceptionnel qui est le théâtre
plein air de saint-gilles
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
d'artistes est précisément de musiciens
qui vont faire vivre le festival total
jazz rencontre
bonjour bonjour bienvenue
merci alors denis laporte vous êtes chef
d'orchestre du jazz club de la réunion
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
votre groupe de musiciens écouter les à
ce club de la réunion c'est ce qu'on
appelle un big band un grand groupe si
j'avais à traduire en gros un orchestre
c'est c'est ce qui est ce qui représente
un peu la tradition des orchestres de
jazz
donc c'est un orchestre d'une vingtaine
de personnes à peu près avec une section
rythmique et puis un grand pupitre de
saxophone un grand public de trombone et
un grand plus peter de trompette
d'accord et si j'ai bien compris on les
retrouve différentes générations de
musiciens
oui
mais ça ça tient de ça tient de
l'histoire de de cet orchestre le jazz
club de la réunion que les réunionnais
et connaissent très très bien puisque
c'est un orchestre qui est née il ya il
ya 40 ans exactement
de l'envié musiciens qui étaient là à
l'époque moi j'étais pas à la réunion à
l'époque mais qui était quitter la cave
une envie forte de jouer ensemble et
puis de défendre cette belle musique et
en tant que chef d'orchestre
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on transmet
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec tous ces
musiciens justement pour faire vivre le
jazz à la fois quand on est ce que moi
même je dirige d'autres hors caisse des
orchestres d'harmonie or qu'est
symphonique
mais la particularité des des orchestres
de jazz comme les big band c'est des
orchestres ou l'écriture est une
écriture très vertical souvent est en
tout cas très rythmique
donc en réalité la façon de travailler
peut se rapprocher pour ce qui est des
équilibres des pupilles du travail d'
équilibre des pupitres des soufflant
notamment ça peut tout à fait se
rapprocher de ce qu'on retrouve dans les
orchestres symphoniques que les orques
les harmonies pour autant la manière de
diriger très très différente c'est à
dire que le rôle d'un chef d'orchestre
en tout cas pour moi dans un big band
c'est de souligner les parties
essentielles de la partition et surtout
à mon avis de transmettre l'énergie
collectif collective qui va qui va
donner toute la pêche tout toute la
puissance de cette musique de big bang
quoi et alors justement votre votre
musique donc s'inspire de différents
repères répertoire donc des reprises de
grands jazzmen américains des standards
on va dire des grands classiques
pourquoi ce choix bah c'est l'adn depuis
toujours je crois de cet orchestre de
jazz club de la réunion et en plus le
jazz club de la réunion depuis très
longtemps déjà a choisi aussi de de
jouer
de jouer avec chanteur est ce qui du
coup orientent leur quête vers un
certain type de standards comme vous le
dites
non
si on revient sur le festival total jazz
qu'est ce que vous voulez partager
qu'est ce que vous voulez échanger avec
le public notamment au sein de votre
groupe
ben moi ce que j'ai ce que je on a
construit un vous l'avez dit un
programme autour de standards mais
autour de standards qui n'ont pas
raconte l'histoire du jazz parce que
l'histoire du jazz elle est colossal
donc c'est pas on n'a pas du tout cette
prétention là mais par contre ce qu'on a
envie c'est que pendant sept heures de
partage avec le public c'est de les
emmener à prendre un peu de hauteur un
peu de recul sur ce que c'est que cette
musique ces fameux standard et qu'est ce
qu'il raconte du vivant et de l'époque
où ça a été fait quoi si je prends
premier morceau qui va nous permettre
d'ouvrir la soirée caravane bas j'ai
presque envie de dire que c'est un
morceau qui racontent ce que visait les
musiciens et on l'entend dans la musique
c'est une musique extrêmement figurative
on entend les klaxons de voitures lac
locomotive qui fait du bruit la foule
les la circulation on entend ça et donc
duke ellington il a écrit cette musique
vraiment avec ce qui habitait son
quotidien d'humains donc j'ai ce que
j'ai envie de partager je crois ce soir
là c'est que qu'est ce que nous raconte
cette musique ses standards sur la part
humaine de ces génies noirs américains
qui ont fait que le jazz et le jazz quoi
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce qu'il
raconte est en filigrane dans leur
musique quoi voilà ce que j'ai envie de
vivre et de partager et de partager avec
le public madoni l'apôtre merci d'être
venu nous parler de votre goût et un
plaisir vous allez partager lors de
cette 7e édition de total jazz
ouais bon à très bientôt bannu nous on
est on est plus que ravi de venir ici
surtout que comme je vous le disais
ça correspond à voilà presque à une date
anniversaire donc on est fier de venir
ici puis fier de d'emmener avec nous sur
cette scène là tous les gens qui font
depuis quarante ans que c'est henri
qu'un orchestre existe donc on on sera
une vingtaine sur scène mais dans notre
coeur on sera bien plus que ça le rendez
vous est pris alors à bientôt aléatoire
au revoir